okay so this morning I talked to you
about things that were fairly classic
and that means that they're in my book
from 1997 which you can get upstairs or
in you're an Amazon and today I'm going
to talk about some right now I'm going
to talk about some topics that my guys
that are actually also discussed in the
book but I'm going to discuss them in
ways that are not in the book there the
post book so subjects raise and suffix
array is suffix trees are really
tremendous some people consider them the
data structure but I think of them also
was just a defining an organizing
concept for a lot of different
algorithms and these were invented in
nineteen seventies in ravenna good night
around nineteen seventy three or so and
had a reputation of that nobody other
than the person who invented them which
was a guy named Peter liner and the
second person mccreight who did a
similar thing they were the only two
people who could understand them and it
was as completely understood not humanly
understandable and I was fortunate when
I was on the faculty it's about that it
wasn't about that time and the only I
can aight he's one of the graduate
students guy named josh cohen was now
Josh Bonello wonder if anybody knows him
Brooks and security but for his
qualifying exam he was asked to
understand one of these and so I kind of
started to understand it from the work
that he did and then later esco you
conan actually came up with a very
understandable version and so after i
had written up viners and mccrite
surgeon you know conan came out i had to
throw out that those chapters and
rewrite it the way the conan is okay so
with that background let me to sell you
a little bit about what they are and
then how they've evolved
so a suffix tree is a a way of
organizing all the suffixes in a string
so we have the string Mississippi and I
this is a suffolk street for it and what
we see is one node one leaf sorry for
each one of the suffixes of Mississippi
oh we're absolutely adding a dollar sign
at the end and the dollar sign is always
considered to be lexicographically
smaller than any of the other characters
so the this the suffix of this with
dollar sign is of course just starting
at position one is just the whole string
itself mi SS is si ppi with the dollar
sign and then the subjects starting for
example position to is is si I ssis SI
PP doesn't have the nice rhythm so
anyway but it's this everything but the
first m and all the other suffixes are
in there twelve of them including the
the dollar sign by itself and one of the
properties that's well and what the
suffix tree takes advantage of all the
commonalities so suffix is five and two
both begin with I and therefore the tree
just has a single I here and then walks
down to five for the fifth suffix and
also walks down to two for the second
suffix so we're encoding in this way all
the suffixes but taking taking advantage
of repetitions in the suffixes again
here's here's SSI is the beginning of
Suffolk six but it's also the beginning
of subjects three and so if you want to
think of it that this naively you just
think of a try well TR IE or a tree
where your your person your first
putting in suffix one and you have all
the letters and then you put in suffix
to if suffix to agreed with suffix one
for some portion then
it would share that path until the point
where they disagreed well suffix to
actually doesn't it begins with I but
then you have three and four but now
when you go back to 55 begins with I
which shares a path to two and so we go
down until it it it differs so is si is
the suffix that begins a position I one
two three four on five and it's also the
one that begins at position 2 okay so
now there are two things about the
several things about this that are
important one is that if you look at any
node and you look at the first character
on the paths out of that no they're all
distinct okay just the way I was
describing how we would naively build
this that's that's an immediate
consequence so if you ever are trying to
locate a substring let's say is si in
here there's no ambiguity about what
path you would follow you start at the
at the root and if our substring is is
si you follow I and there's only one
edge that his first label is I and then
you'd follow s SI and you'd end up here
okay so given a suffix tree it's easy
then to determine whether a particular
pattern is contained in the text that
was used to build that suffix tree and
in fact this is one of the first
applications of this was that the Z
algorithm I showed you this morning in
order to find weather pattern is inside
of a text you have to process both the
text and the pattern okay but imagine
the context that comes up all the time
and computational biology we have an
enormous database of strings billions of
characters and that's already known and
and fixed and now you have a short
sequence string maybe length 200 or
whatever you consider be short and you
want to find where that occurs inside
the database you don't want to do work
that's proportional to the size of the
database okay you'd like to do work
that's just proportional to the size
we had to move to my machine which is
unfortunately going to do this at some
point it's probably going to bring up
paintings that my father did and I hope
nobody's offended there's some of them
that are evident over 18 here right okay
so huh yeah right anyway so we have this
if you have this enormous database and
you build a suffix tree for it that's
ahead of time then when you have a
pattern and you want to know whether the
pattern is inside that text yeah and
we're also going to get this thing
constantly annoying that's why I was
preferring to use their machine but it
wasn't working if you have a pattern you
won't know whether it's in the text you
just walk down the suffix tree until you
either exhaust the pattern which says
the pattern is in the text or you you
have no way to proceed and you haven't
exhaust the pattern that's the pattern
is not there now if you want to collect
all of them all the occurrences let's
say at is si you walk down is si and at
the leaves you have the the places where
is si occurs it starts a position to and
it starts at position 5 ok so if you
walk down a particular pattern and then
you do a depth-first traversal to pick
up all of the leaves that are beneath
that in the leaf labels you'll find all
of the occurrences of that particular
pattern as well and it takes a little
bit of analysis but the time for
collecting all of the occurrences is
just proportional to the number of them
so you may think ok we went to is aside
but now this suffix tree is huge and
we're gonna walk all the way down to the
leaves and back and so on we're doing a
lot of wasted work but actually every
time you branch because every branch in
here actually leads to it every time you
think of this way every time you branch
you will come to a different leaf so the
traversal time for the subtrees is just
proportional to the number of
leaves and therefore to collect all the
occurrences is just time proportional to
the number of them so this is one of the
the first real applications of suffix
trees that allows you to find short
patterns inside huge but fixed and known
ahead of time texts in time proportional
to the small pattern not involving the
time for the big text but of course you
have to build the suffix tree first all
right now it looks like if this is
annoying but I don't know what to do it
it looks like if you build the suffix
tree for a string of length n it might
take you n squared time the naive
algorithm I just told you about building
where you're going to take each suffix
and walk through the tree till it
diverges that that's n squared time
those a naive algorithm also it looks
like N squared space because here's the
full string and then portion of another
string and so on well it's easy to get
rid of the space annoyance every string
that's that labels an edge is actually a
contiguous substring of the original
pattern so we can encode this just by
start positioning end position okay so
every edge is just can be just coated in
constant space okay so that makes it
plausible that maybe we could actually
compute this thing in linear time okay
obviously the size of the suffix tree is
just proportional to n as I said every
branch leads to a different a different
leaf so since we can now encode what's
on every edge in just constant space now
we have a order n space object for the
suffix tree but we still don't how do
you compute it faster than n squared
well this was the great result of 1973 I
think roughly 73 of a Viner and then
mccrite is that you can build a suffix
tree in linear time time proportional to
the length of the whole string and again
as I mentioned this morning there's
nothing
faster than than that because you have
to touch every character in the input
and only thing faster would be to smell
the string instead of instead of
actually processing it okay so i'm not
going to show you the mccreight
algorithm where the Yukon an algorithm
or the diviner algorithm but I'm going
to show you a more modern way of
building suffix trees that comes through
a later device called a suffix array
there okay so this is just saying some
of the things I've been saying
implicitly the label of a path from a
route the route that ends at a node is
the catenation in order of the
substrings labeling the edges of that
path path label of a note is the label
of the path from the root yeah and for a
node V in a suffix tree the string depth
of V is the number of characters in v's
label okay all right so I SAT a suffix
tree for s can be built in order s time
as should be a parenthesis there we're
Steven okay we'll achieve this through
our discussion of Suffolk's arrays which
will come after I tell you more about
suffix trees so maybe there's a way of
just agreeing to this and getting it to
go away okay so i says the suffix trees
have a huge range of applications and if
you think of them as suffix if you think
of them as a data structure I once told
dick harp that there's a suffix a red
suffix tree algorithm which takes what
had previously been an exponential time
at computation down to a linear time
computation and he said that's that's
very unusual for a data structure
usually data structures will take you
from some nice polynomial down to a much
nicer polynomial so the suffix trees are
not just data structures they're really
also organizing principles for how
you're going to build an algorithm so I
have a couple of applications here i'll
talk about actually just i already
talked about the application of
looking for a small pattern inside of a
large text and that's a very relevant
one in computational biology all pair
suffix prefix overlap that also comes up
in at least in the old days is baubles
Nigeria of sequence assembly okay where
you had a lot of reeds and you need a
defined for each pair of reeds you had
to find the how much the maximum or
actually all of the pre-fall the
suffixes of one which match a prefix of
the other okay so we can just think of
this as two strings and I want to find
all the suffixes of one which match
exactly they don't have to be the same
length strings even that's that okay
but actually get on what Stephen had
asked this morning so this morning
talking about longest common subsequence
and we did that with dynamic programming
and then Stephen asked Steven Brenner
asked about longest common substring
okay so let me do that one instead is I
mean there are probably I probably know
50 60 applications non-trivial
applications and I do want to talk about
the limb polls it as well but let me
talk about longest common substring and
might talk about that too longest common
substring of two strings don't have to
be the same length so this is alpha and
this is alpha okay and so there a
substring is contiguous subsequence can
be broken up by by spaces or other
characters so we want to find what is
the longest string in one sequence which
is also in the other one okay and you
can think of naive algorithms but they
certainly wouldn't be linear time lets
us say they're both of the same length
so we want order n and I believe this is
a problem that was conjectured by knuth
at least one of these classic problems
was conjectured by knuth to not be
solvable in linear time only on log n
time would be possible but let me just
show you how you do this in in when your
time using a suffix tree so yeah let's
say I built a string which is s 1
concatenated with us too and I'll put
some something in there just to separate
them probably really don't really need
that and then I build a suffix tree for
that s and I've told you i've advertised
at least that we can build suffix trees
in linear time okay now
then we can just by doing a either a
bottom-up or a depth-first traversal or
whatever so every every leaf here is
indexed by its position in s okay so we
know which one of these come from s 1
and which one of these come from s 2 and
maybe even there's one that comes from
both okay so every leaf we can say that
is a stat is a I'm sorry because of the
dollar sign anyway for other reasons
either when each one will either be from
s 1 with a dollar sign or from s 2 okay
let me back up a little bit we can have
generalized suffix trees which encode a
set of suffixes even if they're not from
the same string okay so we can have all
the suffixes from s 1 and all the
subjects is from s 2 encoded in a single
suffix tree like okay so in that case
every leaf either comes from a suffix
it's an S one or a suffix and s2 and I
was just trying to be fancy by
concatenating these let's just say we
have that so we have a suffix tree that
represents all the suffixes either they
come from s1 or they come from us too
okay now visually looking at this what
is the longest common substring it's the
longest path where we count with a path
by its string depth that is how many
characters are on here it's the longest
path along a string depth of a path down
to a node maybe this branches off down
to some node which is an ancestor of a
Suffolk this that comes from s 1 and the
subjects that comes from s 2 okay you
can think of conversely the longest
common substring is a prefix of a suffix
any substring is a prefix of the suffix
so every substring is a walk from the
root down to somewhere
okay partial walk doesn't have to come
to the leaves so we walk down here this
is this substring is common to both s 1
and s 2 because there are leaves beneath
here that are one that's labeled us one
link labeled s2 so all we have to do to
find the longest common substring once
we built the suffix tree for both s1 and
s2 as we take a walk depth-first
traversal whatever and and note when we
have we bumped in yet now I'm going to
the bottom up okay should never talk
about something I haven't prepared but
anyway bottom up I'm just going to note
whether we've seen an s-1 beneath your
bottom up means from the leaves so here
we've seen an s-1 you you convey that
information to hear here we've seen an
s2 you convey that information to hear
here we've seen you convey that
information upwards so this is a node
that's seen both s1 and s2 so we can
label every node with to note whether
beneath it there's something from s1 and
something from s2 and then we can just
do with that first reversal to find the
deepest one of those the ones with the
largest string depth okay so that's how
you can do longest common substring in
linear time obviously all the work I was
just talking about is doable in linear
time
ok any questions on that lots of
different applications so I'm going to
talk about Lempel Ziv compression which
is something very important and widely
used there are several papers about
Lempel Ziv sometimes this is it
sometimes it's Lempel Ziv sometimes as
if Lempel and I thought okay that's
because they're you know they're sharing
the the credit sometimes they will
invert it well then I realized well
maybe that's just the difference between
reading the names in English or breeding
them in Hebrew okay so I mean if they
actually always rule impulsive but you
read it that way then it simple or I
don't know what's the convention in
Hebrew if you have a two names I mean I
know what the convention is if you have
numbers you know you're reading like
this and you run right to left and you
run for the number one two three you
don't call it three two one you jump up
anyway side I can't sali y 76 paper is
or the left loves it okay the real paper
77 and 78 hours even them okay okay okay
so it's just a venir el Z or Z 0 you can
find them that way very paper important
results there isn't the switching okay
all right so what is so it's a data
compression so string compression method
okay so you take a long string and you
want to compress it into smaller
obviously it has to be invertible you
have to be able to go backwards and get
the original string from from the
compressed one and the basic idea is
well this this is a little bit of a
knockoff of the real idea but it's it's
close enough to get the to get the gist
of it is here's this long string that
we're trying to compress and here i have
this a be a XC a B etc etc etc well so
you start with the letter A because what
can you do I mean you have nothing to go
on you have to start on the
first letter and then from the next
position you ask what's the longest
what's the longest substring starting
from here that has been seen before in
this in the string okay well in this
case it sits there isn't one it's Abby
so you output be also okay then and you
move on one position then you have ok
this is this example is going to take us
very far very fast then you have ax well
you a has appeared before so now you can
write down that this character has been
seen at position starting a position one
and that stub something is the length
one ok so that's great compression
you've just converted one character into
one two three four five okay so it
doesn't get them an advantage until you
until quite a ways away so let's say we
have a BA X see okay so now when you get
out to here ABA XC has been seen before
okay that does occur and so instead of
writing out anyone any portion of this
you just say oh this is a position
starting position one and four five
characters that's my representation of
it so in this particular little example
had broken even at that at that point
now in this little example so far every
repeated occurrence or prior occurrence
was from the first position okay so we
could do that with the Z algorithm write
as e algorithm would say from every
position what's the longest substring
there that equals a prefix but we want
to do it more generally for any previous
so you have a be a X let's make this
really long okay and it starts here at
position
1001 and then later you have it again a
XYZ and you're at a point in the limb
poles of compression algorithm work
you've compressed everything you've
represented everything up to this point
now you have to represent what's left
and so you again you ask what's the
longest substring that starts here and
has occurred previously in the string
that we've processed and so here we
would if we can find that quickly we
would say 1001 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 ok so we
replace 7 characters by five or whatever
and you can see this this you know the
real advantage comes when the sequences
are long and there's a lot of repetition
which there is in DNA okay and there is
in English and this is the actually the
basis for but one more thing when you
get to a position if you get to a
position where there is none let's say
you have a w aw has never occurred
before then you out you obviously output
w okay so here we're having some
notation that says the same thing and
the next slide is even worse pseudocode
we just basically says do what I just
said you start at i equals 1 and you
compute the first position where there's
a substring starting a position i which
is equal to the substring that starts at
li and this is its length SI and if you
actually found one back there then you
just output the starting position on the
length yeah this is the length is the
starting position and you increment now
I plus Li because you can jump over all
of those ones okay this is just notation
is it does anybody explain it a little
bit better but it's a saying in
pseudocode what I was just
when I was just saying it is you're at a
position I and you want it does is there
a substring that starts at position I
which has occurred before and you want
the first occurrence of that and that
would be at SI and its length is Li so
you would for here you would just then
output SI li and then skip li positions
to hear and that's when you have to
start compressing again or do the same
thing otherwise if Li is not bigger than
0 there's no there's no previous
occurrence of any pattern that starts at
position I then you just output that
particular character single character
and you move over by one position
everybody got it okay that's the level
that really is with some little
embellishments the lipuls of data
compression and there's a lot of
engineering on top of that that people
have done and so when you read those
papers you get easily swamped by all the
the data engineering software
engineering and algorithm engineering
but it's really that simple and it has
all kinds of provable properties of
coming close to Shannon compression
bounds and you know it's it's pretty
much optimal now in English this is the
this is the basis for I think called
bzip which is a unix utility and English
it compresses maybe typical down to
one-fifth of the size but in DNA which
is first of all shorter smaller alphabet
and lots of repetitions that I've been
told the compression is much greater I
don't know exactly but okay well how do
we implement this algorithm that just
told you about it's really simple you
build a suffix tree for s okay
all right and then after we built the
suffix tree for s we're going to process
yet with a linear time traversal which
will label every node V remember this is
a well there's a string down to V we're
going to label and each one of these is
a starting position in s position s as
if we're just going to let's say this as
3724 we're just going to label this with
the smallest of these so that's the
leftmost occurrence of this string so we
label that with v with three okay v it
with three so and again this is easy
processing just bottom up what's the
smallest number that you've seen beneath
it you label it with that okay so then
as i'm doing the zip Lempel algorithm
the limpid zip algorithm I we get to a
point where I have to compress the rest
of these things and remember what am I
trying to compute here I'm trying to
compute what is the longest substring
that starts at I which is a current
somewhere previously okay well so you
just go to the root of the suffix tree
and you start walking down this you
start walking down this string that
you're seeing in here okay until you
can't proceed any further there's the
next character over here is not your
place where the next character here is
not the next character you would
encounter in that walk okay so that has
found the longest prolonged substring
that starts a position I that occur
somewhere previously and where is it
well you might not actually end up in a
node you might end up somewhere in the
middle but where that previous
occurrences is
written at the first node beneath where
you stopped because that was the the
left does the smallest number beneath
here we've already pre-processed those
and what there's actually one little
extra sub case what happens if you have
overlapping occurrences that is you you
find so this goes way out and here's it
work it begins again it goes all the way
to here okay so you have to pay
attention to that so you take this
number you take this length and if you
if it goes too far then you chop it off
that's it and what was the time well
starting from here the time was
proportional to the length of the of the
substring that you were walking along I
should have mentioned that the alphabet
we're dealing with us is constant of
constant size ok we have a fixed
alphabet so it has size 256 or something
a thousand whatever which means that
when you get to a node and it branches
multiple ways and you want to follow one
that's labeled see even without any
fancy data structures because this out
degree is bounded by the size of the
alphabet it's just constant time to find
what edge you should proceed on and
therefore the walk is just time
proportional to the length of what you
find did your question Yeah right right
right right we're going to walk down
that yeah well it's just that the using
the interval to that the constant size
representation of the string and a
substring is just so that the whole data
structure is within linear space as if
it wasn't within linear space then it
wouldn't you couldn't build it in linear
time but yes you actually have to look
so you have to also have a well you have
a copy of the string and you have to
look at those characters and so that's
it when you're walking down here you're
also making progress in the string that
is when you found that there's a match
their of length i li then I is being
incremented by Li okay so you found
there's a match here of length L I and
where you next start working again is it
the LI plus one so it takes you time
proportional to L I to get to do this
walk but then you get to skip over
exactly that many characters in the
string and therefore the total work and
the algorithm is just linear in the
length of the string so in linear time
using suffix trees we're able to do the
live zone or whatever LZ data
compression and again the key thing that
the suffix tree gave you that the Z
algorithm did not is the ability to find
the longest substring that begins at a
position I that occurs somewhere
anywhere in the previous or actually the
first occurrence in the previous and not
just at prefix so the Z algorithm gave
you that nice prefix information but you
didn't it didn't pick up that
information okay and it's sort of
similar to longest common substring as
well it's a very similar idea okay so
that was you know one of many many many
applications non-trivial applications of
of suffix trees okay suffix arrays came
along some what about the same time
maybe a little later and are usually
credited to Miller admirers Meyers of
jean meyers fame before he was jean
meyers he he did this had a number of
other things too and this is a more
compact representation of the suffixes
in a string and people who actually do
implementations which I don't say that
it can
to about a fifth of space okay and what
is the suffix array for s it's just the
list of the s suffix starting positions
ordered Lex graphically by the
lexicographic ordering of their suffixes
okay so here's yeah here's the suffix
tree for mississippi again okay and
alexa graphically smallest suffix is
just a dollar sign by itself so the
first entry in the suffix array is 12
representing the start of the
lexicographically smallest suffix okay
then the next entry is 1111 is its I
dollar sign that's the string okay and I
dollar sign is actually the second
smallest Lex graphically smallest
substring really know what i mean by Lex
graphically I mean that's what the way
you would find things in the dictionary
okay a purely coincidental that this was
well no it's not coincidental the dollar
sign there's always at the end is the
smallest because was defined to be small
but it's coincidental that the second
smallest was just at the end there ok so
the third one is a position eight which
is saying that one two three four five
six seven eight I ppi dollar sign is the
third smallest suffix LexA graphically
smallest suffix okay and so the suffix
array here is just what I said it's a
list of the suffix starting positions in
lex graphically in lexicographic order
of the suffixes themselves okay now from
a suffix tree you can get the suffix
array in linear time and we can build a
suffix tree in linear times ergo we can
build a suffix array in linear time and
what's what's the suffix array it's just
you take the suffix tree and you do a
lexicographic depth-first search of the
suffix tree lexicographic means whenever
you come to a node and you have to
decide which way should you go
you go with the smallest of the
characters that the first characters
that label those edges so you're always
trying to find the next
lexicographically smallest suffix so
here here we would the smallest here is
a dollar sign come back to here among
the ones that we haven't reversed yet
the smallest is an eye here down a
dollar sign and you pick up the leaves
as you encounter them twelve eleven back
up to here elemento p @ p comes before s
so you're next that doesn't wait a
minute oh yeah sorry yeah all right p
comes before s so you come down here you
pick up eight and come back up here s
down to here p again comes before s and
you can pick up five and so on so a
lexicographic depth-first traversal of a
suffix tree gives you a suffix array and
i find that very very helpful to keep
that picture in mind when we talk about
suffix arrays because we're not actually
going to our algorithms aren't going to
use suffix trees okay so but
conceptually that's what a suffix array
is okay now a suffix array is obviously
it's a smaller object in a suffix tree
so it has lesson sort of hand waving as
less information in it but if you have a
suffix array and you have another array
that's called LCP which is the same
roughly the same size as the suffix
array subjects array is AB length
proportional to the string we're dealing
with and LCP array which I'll tell you
about is also proportional to about the
same size most of the fancy fast
algorithms and I said there I don't know
maybe there's 100 nice applications that
use suffix trees can be converted to an
algorithm that works just on the suffix
array plus this LCP array and has the
same running time sometimes those
algorithms are simpler than on suffix
trees usually they're a little bit more
complicated but so far every one of the
nice al
nice linear time results on suffix trees
have been doable on suffix arrays I
don't think there's a general theorem
that says that's always possible but yes
there is because I'll show you that you
can always convert a suffix array plus
LCP into a suffix tree okay but we want
always to do this within just two arrays
when the size of the suffix array and
well the only other one the size of the
suffix array okay so that's the
constraint not a typical kind of
constraint and complexity kinds of
analysis algorithm complexity analysis
because there its asymptotic but here
we're really trying to be practical
we're saying we only we don't want to
build a suffix tree because suffix trees
tend to be about five times the size of
a suffix array and so we want all these
algorithms to just work on a suffix
array and some other array which is the
same size okay so is that using a suffix
tree to build a suffix array defeats the
space savings and so an open problem for
about ten years was to find an algorithm
to build a suffix array in linear time
obviously but only using s and one added
array of size us okay and that was open
for obviously ten years I didn't making
these slices and bother to check its
might even be longer than that around
two thousand three in the same year
three into pit three independent
solutions were published it's like one
after another and they really were
independent that nobody knew about the
other one and so I don't know how this
happens but it's certainly not the first
time and the car karriem if I remember
it's a finished name if I'm pronouncing
it right and Sanders is the solution
that's the most elegant and I'll try to
tell you a little bit about it I don't
have a lot of time less but it's it is
so cute or at least what makes it work
compared to what everybody else tried
and that was one of them who tried and
failed so here's a failed attempt
remember what is our what is our object
where's our objective we want to build a
suffix array in linear time because we
know that's doable a suffix
tree and we want to but we don't want to
use a suffix tree we just want to use
the string s obviously and one other
array in this case okay so here's a
failed attempt so you can let me define
a generalized suffix array is a it's a
basically the subjects array for a
strict subset of all the subjects is an
S so remember I said the look the suffix
array is a listing of the positions of
the suffixes in the lexicographic order
of those suffixes well i can define
coming up with a list of if i'm just
interested in the subset of the suffixes
then i can still talk about their
lectric graphic order and have a list of
those right okay I'll call that a
generalized suffix array okay so what
you can do is you can take s and divide
it into the odd positions and we're
going to have the suffix starts position
1 so if it starts position 3 5 7 and so
on and the suffixes that start at the
even positions okay two four six eight
and so on and then recursively find the
gsa for those for those two lists okay
those two sets of positions the suffix
array for the even positions of subjects
array for the odd positions and then and
internally again they're ordering
anybody who does merge sort or any of
those classic will see that this is
going to work you merge the two GSA's to
form a suffix array of of the entire
string well what does it mean to merge
let's say I have 3 7 15 so this is the
suffix array for the odd positions I
just made up these lists by the way so
don't think don't try to create a string
where this actually is but imagine that
this is the list this is the generalized
suffix array for the odd positions of
some string and this is the general I
suffix array for the even positions of
some string and now I want a true self
array for all of the positions in the
string although suffix is in the string
well this is the lex graphically
smallest from the EP from the odd
positions this is Lex graphically
smallest for the even and now I just
need to find out which of those two is
actually Lex graphically smallest okay
is it the one that starts a position
three or the one that starts a position
six well the obvious way of doing that
so I have a pen that doesn't work well I
have the subjects that begin the
position three in the sub because it
means a position six and I've got my two
fingers and I go like that until they
are agreeing until they disagree ok and
then x is smaller than Y so this is the
lexicographically this is Mexico
actually smaller than three and so I
output six ok and then I compared the
suffix starting it what happened did I
skip okay and then I since six was
output now I compare the subjects of
being is at three with the subject
begins at four and so on ok and and you
can see just the same way that merge
sort works that the result of merging
this way will will give us a suffix
array of of s okay well obviously if you
actually do the two-finger approach how
long does it take to merge two suffixes
is proportional to the length of their
agreement anyway but at worse case it's
going to be there their entire length
and so that merging of two lists is not
going to be doable in order around time
even it's it's going to be some likely
and squared and people tried very very
hard to be clever find all kinds of
clever ways to do merging
would defeat that and nobody ever
succeeded that way but we all came up
with lots of algorithms that have that
time bound I Rowan that was long and
baroque and it was never published
because it was too Baroque and it's not
broke don't fit anyway so that's where
it's sat for a while until car carrion
and Sanders and these other ones and to
me this is this is a story that I would
love it if I met one of them and they
said oh you know just one day I was
taking this long shower and it hit me
because it's one of those it's just one
of those little ideas that if you don't
divide the suffixes into odd and even
positions but instead you divide them
into those that start at positions 1 or
2 mod 3 versus those that start a
position 0 mod 3 ok so I mean one list
is going to be the positions of 1 and 2
mod 3 any other 013 so first list is
twice the size of the second list but
you divide them that way then then you
recursively
then the merging is trivial and so I'll
show you Plus once you have the you're
going to recursively find the
generalized suffix array for the
suffixes that start at position 1 and 2
mod 3 do that recursively and when
you've done that you can actually find
the suffix array for the ones that start
at position 0 mod 3 in linear time once
and for all not recursively okay so let
me let me till those are the two ideas I
have to tell you about how you get the
second general I suffix array for the
ones that started position 0 mod 3
quickly if you already have the first
one and then secondly how you to the
merging which is really the cute thing
that you know I wish I hit me well
taking a shower so rank of j that's the
position in the generalized suffix array
for suffix j that's just where it is
okay so if i have a generalized suffix
array 3517 ok so the rank of 1 is 3 it's
in the third it's the third smallest ok
so that's the only hopefully that's the
only notation you have to keep in your
head the stuff gets very can get very
tricky ok now if we've already
recursively computed the gsa for the
first set the one or two mod three
positions and then we want to compute
the gsa for the second set those are the
0 blood three positions we can do that
in order s time or the length of the
string that's total time not recursive
we're this isn't you do it once and for
all it's not a recursive type algorithm
because what you do is for each position
I in the second set those are the ones
that are at position 0 mod 3 you form
the two symbols string what that
character actually is and what it's
what's the rank of the next character in
the string that since this is 0 mod 3
this is 1 mod 3
okay so I plus 1 is in the is in the
first general suffix array so we take
that symbol we take that rank which is
just a number and that's my two symbol
alphabet to simple string and then we
use radix sort on these strings to get
the GSA of the second set there's some
little bookkeeping in bulk let's say
this what happened there so and this is
not in any kind of order this is a sort
of random ordering this is 3426 1758
those are the numbers that are one or
two mod three we have a string length 8
and so we have symbol d is in some
position okay and it's right then the
next character / is ranked three in the
first general a suffix array okay so it
says it's the third lexicographically
smallest string among the strings that
begin a position one or two months three
okay but I do I have to be the
bookkeeping means i have to know where
this actually this d came from in the
original string as well that's something
I have to keep but if I do a radix sort
of this then I'm going to get a 1 a 4 a
5 c7 d2 d3 da so it's it's taking all of
the D just think of it this way you've
got suffixes at position 0 mod 3 that
begin with the letter D and I want them
no suffix is in lexicographic order well
obviously they all begin with d so the
key thing to know is which is
lexicographically smaller starting from
the next position over but the next
position over is is a one in position
which is one mod three and you already
know the ordering there so and the rank
is what tells you that and you can just
treat that as a number
so that you when you Lex graphically
sort these now you have the
lexicographic ordering of all the
suffixes that begin at position 0 mod 3
again there's some bookkeeping because
you have to know where this came from as
opposed to this age came from in the
original string s okay but this is just
linear time and so once you get this one
which is going to be done recursively
this one comes in order n time that's
cool but we have to merge okay so now we
have our two I didn't type set properly
now we have our two
what happened to this something's
missing here but okay it's all right now
we have our two general I suffix arrays
and I'm almost done here it's just
another another two minutes for this and
that's basically going to be the end of
this took so we have our generalized
suffix array for positions 1 and 2 mod 3
and we have a generalized suffix array
for positions 0 mod 3 ok and I told you
before how you merge how you merge two
lists you could just do the two fingers
but that wouldn't be the time we want ok
so but you never compare anything inside
here or anything inside here because
these are already ordered and these are
already ordered all right and this is
the punchline this is the really fun
thing that that they observed so when
i'm doing a comparison let's say 'let's
at the very beginning should have had
anything i have an example of it it's
not shutting up
anyway position 5 so 5 is the the
subjects that starts a position 5 is
lexicographically smallest suffix that
starts at positions 1 or 2 mod three and
what's a zero month 39 okay okay so I'm
now looking into here here's position 5
here's position nine I look at these two
characters if they're different X Y then
I know which to which is Lex graphically
smallest I'm done okay one operation but
if they're not if they're the same okay
then I what do I have to do I'd move
over I'd look at the position six and
position ten okay well 6 is still this
is this is this is one or two mod three
okay now this is 0 mod three position 0
mod 3 and this is a position 1 or 5 1 or
2 mod three ok so again because they're
in different lists I have to look at
these two characters and maybe if the if
they're different than fine we're done
again whichever of these two is the
smallest we're done but if they're equal
I've got to move over I don't know why
I'm you're racing that CW but what do I
move over to I move over to 11 here and
I move over 27 here okay seven and
eleven something about dice 7 11 those
are both 1 mod 3 or 1 or 2 months 3
sorry go so this is one mod 3 what's 11
13 right okay everybody get the point by
the third character comparison
you are now in two character two
positions which are in the same list ok
1 a 2 month 3 so you know their
relationship remember you're going to
also have things like ranks so you can
just look up what is the rank of 7 in
this list and what is the rank of 11 in
this list and now you know which of
those two is Lex graphically smaller and
so now you know whether the string
starting here is Lex graphically smaller
or larger than the string starting here
so within three character comparisons at
most you can you can determine that and
then that means we decide which one of
those two positions we output which
means we can do this merge of the two
lists in time proportional to the length
of the two lists so we have the
I'm just trying to find the wrote down
the recurrence relation the time
analysis somewhere in here yeah okay so
what's the time for this algorithm well
you have the positions 1 and 2 mod 3 so
that's about two-thirds of s and you
have to find their gsa recursively so
the time to process a string of length s
is just one of those it's a recursive
call here on something that's that size
okay then as I the other general I
suffix array is found in time order s
right it's what we did and then the
merging is time order s okay so you have
this recurrence relation and hopefully
that's linear that solves to order s
okay so why don't haven't I actually
told you is the details of how you do
the the GSA of the first I just said you
do it recursively but there are some
details and those are pretty standard
but quite annoying and I should have
said that the so the real novelty and
because all these other these pieces
were all in place when people were
trying the real novelty was recognizing
that if I divided up the suffixes in
this weird way the merge would be easy
and that's been generalized in all kinds
of different ways different ways you can
divide things up but bomb oh yeah so I
do have videos for sale outside they'll
be happy i have videos online if you
look at my website that I've videos of
this entire subject in about an hour and
a half and it has all of the gory
details if you want to find out all the
pieces but this is the this is the
clever thing here and do I have any more
on this that's is it
thank you oh but i should say one more
thing i'll do it next lecture I didn't
tell you how to find the LCP or even
what it is okay so i'll do that next
time and then when you have the suffix
array on the LCP you can actually build
a suffix tree also so that gives you the
linear time algorithm for building the
suffix tree but i'll fold that into the
next lecture because i'm running way
over time